ce en dit long sur l'état de la justice
aujourd'hui moi j'ai reçu la
notification de mise en examen hier soir
chez moi à l'heure où le jour même où
une journaliste et un habitant de la
ville de roubaix qui est à peu près
similaire dans ses preuves à la ville de
trappes était placée sous protection
policière parce qu'ils ont dénoncé le
réel certes ils ont dit que
ce que j'ai dit moi c'est à dire que se
constitue aujourd'hui sur tout le
territoire français dès territoires où
c'est plus la france où c'est plus les
lois de la république qui s'applique
mais c'est un autre droit donc je
maintiens mes propos trap est éminemment
une petite république islamique en
miniature quand vous êtes dans une ville
d'être mis en examen en capitale
européenne du jihad sauf que là la ville
en europe qui a envoyé le plus de
djihadistes combattre en syrie depuis
depuis 2013 1 85 personnes sont parties
ces mots ne sont pas de moi mais de mes
de gilles kepel quand vous avez des bars
des bars c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
dans l'express je lisais un article de
2018 où les personnels du bar 10 on a
été obligé d'arrêter de vendre de
l'alcool pour faire revenir les clients
parce que la culture à majorité
musulmane c'est un habitant de la plains
commerçants de la place du marché qui
l'a dit n'était plus en adéquation avec
les bars dans lesquels on vendait de
l'alcool quand vous n'avez plus que 4
coiffure mixte sur 13 4 coiffure mixte
yeux monsieur le maire qui avec avait
indiqué ce chiffre 4 coiffure mixte sur
13 tirs des coiffeurs où on peut encore
venir avec hommes et femmes on n'est
plus en france on n'est plus dans les
traditions françaises on n'est plus dans
la république en fait on est dans autre
chose quand vous avez des enseignants
d'histoire en souvient de didier lemaire
qui sont placés sous protection
policière parce qu'on veut placer sous
protection policière il ya une étude qui
est faite par les services de l'état ça
vous tombe pas comme ça sous le nez
parce qu'il a été menacé parce qu'il a
dénoncé les pressions islamistes sur ce
quartier on n'est plus en france on est
dans autre chose et moi ce que je dis
c'est que tu rappes roubaix saint denis
la ville où j'ai grandi
et tant d'autres quartiers en france
c'est notre futur sakho si on reprend
pas en jeu en main maintenant la
situation alors ce qu'on connaît à
trappes on le connaîtra demain donc dans
d'innombrables villes françaises à
revenir sur tours sur votre mise en
examen pour avoir 10 ans oui je suis et
on dansait j'aime y est
et ce qui est hallucinant c'est que la
justice en fait poursuivent le même but
que les islamistes alors que diallo
faire taire ceux qui osent dénoncer dire
quelque chose à l'urban bardella dames
et messieurs bardés là moi je suis
extrêmement choqué avec tout mon respect
par vos propos qui sont très violents et
moi je pense à tous les habitants de
trappes ce sont des habitants qui
essayent de s'en sortir qui s'ouvrent
les stigmatiser vous avez déclaré ces
fausses vient de vous avez déclaré que
trappe en quelque sorte c'est même plus
du communautarisme a fait sécession oui
vous accusez trappe d'être en solo coûte
d'ailleurs il n'y a pas beaucoup de
villes qui sont hors la france monsieur
il ya des habitants qui souffrent avec
souvent des faits répréhensibles que
vous avez dénoncé
d'accord mais vous globalisé vous mettez
tous les habitants dans le même panier
et comme d'habitude vous jouez à faire
peur votre discours sous jacent ces
villes où comme par hasard un plus fort
pourcentage de population musulmane
elles ne sont plus en france encore une
fois vous taper sur les musulmans et ça
c'est pas bien vous êtes attaqué pour
diffamation mais les futures il avoue le
maire et excusez moi mais donc et vous
qu'elle vous dites voilà
vous dites quoi à la journaliste qui est
pas de ma chapelle un pardon à la
journaliste de m6 je la suspecte
rassemblement national qui a été placée
sous protection policière pour avoir
fait un reportage sur la ville de
roubaix qui est une ville à peu près
similaire à trappes ou là bas il ya des
boutiques où on vend des poupées pour
enfants sans le visage parce que dans
les lois du coran il est indiqué qu'on
ne peut pas avoir de reproduction du
corps humain sur sur des produits
dérivés ligne qui vous barrent le chemin
qu'on ferme les yeux sur tout cela mais
ça existe les enseignants qui sont sous
protection policière
les journalistes qui sont menacés il
attrape par exemple la trappe depuis
depuis 2015 ya plus qu'une seule
boucherie traditionnelle c'est-à-dire
une boucherie pour qu'il soit rare sadeq
al hilal et le maire de genève aux
annonceurs ya un changement de
population qui s'est opéré je ne
stigmatise pas tout le monde je ne mets
pas tout le monde dans le même sac mais
le fait que 85 personnes soient partis
faire le djihad veut bien dire que
l'islamisme radical aujourd'hui de la
barre se nourrissent sur le terreau du
communautarisme et l'immigration